jeden moment meiner lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der micro commands heute am
freitag
das war mein stift ich habe mir wieder
coole commands rausgesucht und werdet
ihr euch jetzt vorstellen ist in diesmal
nicht so kommen die beispielsweise das
einfach mal eine komplette stadt
erschaffen wir dabei sind auch ganz
interessante und nützliche sachen wie
beispielsweise explosionen dann will ich
auf jeden fall der angefreundet startet
bei den fünffachen und liefern an
mit command nummer roman nummer eins
wurde mir zugesendet von cello und zwar
beschreibt dieser command das ist dann
so aussieht als wenn ich das spiel
verlassen würde also im chat sieht so
aus als hätte ich wirklich das spiel
verlassen das kann man dann wieder für
irgendwelche trolling was macht der
willicher damm riesa command macht klar
wie einfach dass es so aussieht als wenn
ich das spiel letzten wird und was ist
dieser command schrägstrich teltow als
avatar also at alle ein fachtext extra
text kontraste has left the game carla
in yellow und dann sieht das ganze so
aus kommt kraft das letzte game
und wenn ich das spiel verlassen sieht
es nämlich genau so aus das kennt ihr
denkt ich von allen servern und das ist
auch schon command nummer eins so
freunde command nummer 2 zugesendet von
mitch basta 0 07 uhr laufen die ganzen
zombies in bahrain
die laufen wieder auf den village eric
boullier
aber gerade dafür ist ja der command
geeignet und zwar wie schon mehrere
zombies sie diesen village oder
verfolgen und dieser kommerz dass ich
alle zombies auf der kompletten welt
direkt in billiger verwandeln das heißt
ich gebe jetzt diesen kommen die einfach
schnell ein und ihr seht schon nur noch
manager am start los der command einfach
aufgebaut schrägstrich ntt data et also
entities type zombie also das ist
zombies sind ist villiger doppelpunkt
einfach so dass sie sich einfach in den
willicher verwandeln und wenn ich das
jetzt noch mal einfach eingeben würde
ich jetzt gerade nichts passieren aber
wenn ich mir jetzt mal eben noch mal
schnell einen zombie suche wo ich das
ganze anwenden kann
bei denen wo haben wir denn hahahahaha
space jockey gut freunde irgendwie habe
ich da wollen wir sehen für das hier
immer so ab und zu ein paar zwei der job
ist einfach sport aber ich habe jetzt
beispielsweise wieder so ein paar
zombies ich gehe mit diesem command ein
und ich habe nur noch billiger und das
ist command nummer zwei und nummer drei
ist eine mega simple sache die wir zu
gesendet wurde von red am keyboard und
zwar kann man somit einfach seinen spawn
setzen wenn ich nämlich jetzt zur zeit
einfach mal / kill mache habe ich
einerseits mein command blog verloren
und die spanne jetzt gerade hier
allerdings wenn ich mir denke der spanne
scheiße und ich gehe nirgendwo hin und
bauen wir jetzt beispielsweise mein haus
also das sieht sehr sehr schön aussehen
damit den ganzen blümchen und das sieht
sehr sehr schön aus dieses blumenwiese
bei und wenn ich mir jetzt einfach sagen
okay ich hab hier oben ein haus gebaut
und hier würde ich auch gerne meinen
sport haben kann man einfach hingehen
und sagen / network gpon und dann bis
der welt ein fixpunkt auf hierhin
gesetzt deswegen weil sie nicht direkt
aber hier soll dem umkreisen wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise nicht einfach mal
hier wieder kill mache dann sportlich
nicht dahinter am arsch der welt sondern
dementsprechend hier oben auf meinem
tollen bergauf und nicht dahinter wurde
das da vorne war das glaube ich amanos
der welt deswegen ist es eigentlich eine
ganz interessante sache viele werden
wahrscheinlich schon kennen aber das ist
auf jeden fall so eine sache wenn man
sich denken
ich habe ihr ausgebaut und auf jeden
fall wollte man nicht abstellen haben
wandern direkt bei meinem haus und das
iss kommando 3 und wir kommen um 3,4
wurde mir zugesendet von wilma kraulen
bestimmt heisst du will mit vornamen und
nachnamen oder wie beim etwas einfach
tiere tnt auf schnellen habe ich mir
dazu notiert und zwar ist es einfach
dieser command zusammen prime tnt dann
diese welle diner mit plus 1 das tnt
über den mob ist und dann habe ich hier
beispielsweise einfach mal eine
fledermaus wenn ich jetzt enter drücken
fledermaus und die wird von tnt geleitet
und jeden moment ddh
aber so ist das halt auch im bett wars
gemacht mit den schafen beispielsweise
wo die dieses komische tnt drauf haben
und dann kann ich jetzt rein theoretisch
auch wenn ich das hier mal habe ich las
den namen jetzt einfach mal gleich kann
ich ihr beispielsweise einfach mal
schief hinschreiben und dann haben wir
auch schon diese tollen teile die wir
immer bei bate wort haben und jeden
moment ist das ist kummer nummer 4 der
mir zu gesendet wurde von bestimmt wilma
und jetzt kommen wir zu command nummer 5
wurde mir zugesendet von let's play bei
uns was ist ein job mit heftiger
ausrüstung normalerweise denke ich mir
sowas ist er relativ unkreativ kreativ
ist sowas wenn einmotten tnt reitet aber
sowas wie einfach nur krass mops machen
ist nicht so ganz nicht so ganz kreativ
aber es sieht einfach so krass aus wenn
ich jetzt diesen giant einfach mal sporn
hat einfach die krasseste rüstung dies
gibt er hat einfach klasse
verzauberungen darauf werten krasse
schwert der macht zwar nix weil es
einfach und giant ist der macht nicht
aber es ist trotzdem einfach den kann
ich jahrelang boxen der wirt ersten zehn
milliarden jahren ist vielleicht ein
bisschen übertrieben aber irgendwann
wird er sterben
und man kann auf jeden fall einem client
auch solche sachen damit anziehen
also es ist nicht so dass man nur mit
rüstung spawnen kann sondern auch den
heftigen giant und der sieht schon mega
böse aus gibt es vor allem bei dem mund
von dem an alter einfach so als hätte er
so megacities in seim und 3d also das
ist command nummer fünf einfach dass so
ein mann dessen namen er heißt kevin hrs
kevin denn kevin hat die heftigste
rüstung ist der krasseste zombie den es
gibt und den kann man mit diesen
commands von der iss megalan der command
deswegen ihr seht ihr halt einfach in
der beschreibung wenn ihr das ganze
selbst testen wollt und das war's dann
auch schon mit dieser folge der commands
habt ihr übrigens erkannt dass ich bei
jedem command immer mal so den shader
gewechselt habe ich habe vier
verschiedene shader und bin da haben wir
so ein bisschen durchgewechselt werden
euch die folge gefallen hat würde ich
mich definitiv über eine bewertung
freuen also einfach den daumen hoch da
lassen dass es einen klick bei euch und
es macht mir immer echt arbeit das ganze
hier zu bearbeiten dass arbeit das ganze
bearbeiten da steckt das wort arbeiten
drin denkt ihr wisst was ich meine und
dann würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr das
nächste mal wieder einschaltet also
nächsten freitag oder heute noch was
komplette loch bin wie die heute kommt
kein video mehr aber morgen kommt
monster legions wieder und eine leben
folge mit kanuten da freue ich mich wenn
er wieder dabei sind hier ist wieder der
stift und
ich habe den genau auf das kabel drauf
geschwistern hat mir das hier falls die
teile runter gerissen
wir sehen uns wieder irgendwann im leben
im leben der wikinger leben wieder